my actual first job was as a camp
counselor when I was 14 possibly 13 way
too young to watch another child but
there I was being paid to do it I hated
riding the bus we had to ride a bus in
the morning I would get out of that as
much as possible because I would always
throw up on the bus a few times I threw
up and we had to clean it up and I
pretend the kid did it it was made
I remember the parents visited one day
and one of the fathers told me that he
thought I wasn't a good counselor that I
was too young to be watching his child
and I agreed with him one of the kids
accidentally knocked over a bunch of
[ __ ] on a shelf once and it hit me on
the head and I remember this kid and I
had trouble you know with each other his
name is Ezra and I said to him Ezra did
you do that by accident or on purpose
and he looked me right in the eyes and
he said purpose [ __ ] Azra but at the end
of the summer I got paid $800 and I
wanted the money so bad that I went to a
check cashing place went up there to the
bulletproof window gave them my check
they said there's a fee I didn't
understand what that meant I said that's
fine
they took basically $700 out of it but
cash money was so much more fun than a
check you know I'd rather have a
hundred-dollar bill than a check for a
thousand
I think I'd go back to camp counseling
for $800 a summer with children I had it
seems yeah this this town this Hollywood
so fleeting you know you can be you can
be out of work in a minute but summer
camp is summer camp is forever